autres titres de l'actualité nicolas
sarkozy at-il mobiliser les services de
sécurité pour connaître l'origine des
rumeurs d'infidélités dans le couple
présidentiel
les rumeurs qui date d'il ya quelques
semaines officiellement la réponse est
non mais la direction du renseignement a
confirmé hier qu'elle avait bien ouvert
une enquête à l'époque la gauche dénonce
déjà un mélange des genres qu'elle vit
un bear sébastien laffargue
il faut mettre un point final à la
sphère des rumeurs ne plus rien en dire
nicolas sarkozy en a fait une priorité
les bruits qui circulent depuis déjà
plusieurs semaines sur de supposés
problèmes au sein du couple
d'abord sur internet puis dans la presse
populaire britannique ces bruits ont
trop duré
hier soir carla bruni-sarkozy elle-même
est monté en première ligne
ces rumeurs sont pour mon mari et pour
moi même insignifiantes
il est vrai que nous avons été victimes
de rumeurs il est vrai que ce n'est pas
très agréable
il est vrai aussi que ça n'a aucune mais
aucune importance
aucune importance ce n'était pas l'avis
de pierre charon un proche conseiller de
l'elysée il ya quelques jours ils y
voyaient une espèce de complot organisé
avec des mouvements financiers
il faut 10 est il que la peur change de
camp nous sommes victimes d'aucun
complot je pense que les rumeurs ont
toujours existé qu'il faut qu'elles sont
inhérentes à l'être humain
il n'y a aucune enquête de police c'est
inimaginable de dire une chose pareille
hier soir pourtant bernard squarcini le
patron de la décennie le
contre-espionnage français affirme
qu'une enquête a bien été diligentée
pour faire la lumière sur l'origine des
rumeurs
mon service a été saisi par mon autorité
de tutelle le directeur général de la
police nationale
du coup ce ne sont plus les rumeurs mais
leurs conséquences et cette fameuse
enquête qui alimentent la polémique
ce qui me choque ce qui m'interroge pour
le moment c'est de savoir sur indication
de qui est ce qu'il y a eu un ordre de
l'elysée est normal que la ce et les
services
renseignements s'intéresse à ceux qui
peuvent comporter des bruits sur la vie
d'un ministre du chef de l'état
aujourd'hui le chef de l'état se rendait
comme chaque année depuis son élection
sur le plateau des glières un haut lieu
de la résistance
les rumeurs sont des mensonges a
expliqué son entourage après l'interview
de carla bruni-sarkozy la sphère est
censé être close